area
I'm looking forward to the talk
hi everybody
um so I'm going to be talking today
about the online list labeling problem
um
this talk has been given many times it
was from Fox 2022 and
um it's I know at least some people at
this Workshop have seen a version of
this talk before and I don't know if
you're just realizing that you might
have seen this before then feel free to
leave I won't be offended okay so
um this is work with
um these set of authors and we were able
to actually get it all in the same place
at the same time and line up in
alphabetical order which was exciting so
Michael Bender Alex Conway Martin farage
Colton um Hanukkah mush Bill kuzmal and
me
the slides were also made
collaboratively with these six authors
so let's get started
okay so I'm going to be talking about
the online list labeling problem
so this is actually not a graph problem
but it is a kind of data structure
primitive and you'll recall from Helen's
talk when she talked about like pmas or
packed memory arrays that's actually the
same thing essentially as the online
list labeling problem it goes by several
different names
and as Helen said like even though this
is just a pure data structure problem it
turns out that it is useful in like
engineering for dynamic graphs in the
sense that she was combining like B
trees and packed memory arrays and using
that to represent uh dynamic graphs in
practice
okay so what is the problem
in this problem we're given uh we have
an array
and what we would like to do is maintain
n elements in this array and we need to
maintain them in sorted order
okay and the array is of size m
and elements are being inserted and
deleted and so uh what we need to do as
elements are getting inserted and
deleted is keep everything in sorted
order and what we're allowed to do is
the algorithm is to move stuff around so
as this insertion comes in we are
allowed to move as many elements around
as we want to and our goal is to
minimize the number of elements that we
move around
for this version of the problem that I'm
going to be talking about imagine that
uh n which is the number of elements in
the array is at most M over 2 for some
value of two just imagine that the array
length is uh constant times the number
of things in the array okay so is the is
the problem clear
so the the number of elements will never
like change by much
oh good question so
um yes imagine imagine here that it
never gets more than maybe it starts
empty it could be less but it never gets
more than like half of the size when you
say elements foreign
you can ask questions both ways for this
talk I'm going to be talking about
amortized
one quick question about the definition
if an element moves five slots do you
pay a cost of five or just one good
question so you can Define it either way
either way is natural for this talk you
can think of it as just the total number
of elements that moved regardless of how
far they moved for the sake of
Simplicity it actually turns out that
our algorithm works even if you do that
cost function uh but for the stock you
can think about it
okay
so
um
just as kind of a intuition for this
problem
um Librarians have been solving it for
many many years and if you wanted to
explain this problem to a child you
might tell them okay imagine you're a
librarian and you have all these books
and you want to keep them in sorted
order and books are being inserted and
deleted and you could imagine two
different types of libraries the library
where you have no gaps between your
books in the library where you have a
lot of gaps between your books and the
intuition is that you know if you don't
have any gaps then you could insert one
book and suddenly have to move like a
ton of books around
so in our problem we want to kind of
cleverly maintain gaps in the array to
allow for new insertions to come in
okay so this problem has been studied a
bunch of times like it was introduced in
like the 80s and studied through the 90s
too it has a bunch of different names
that has been used and was kind of
studied independently by different
groups without them knowing about each
other
it also has a bunch of applications
Helen mentioned some of them let me not
go through these individually but if
you're curious I can like send this to
you okay so what's known about the
problem
so it turns out that what's known about
this problem is that you can get an
upper bound of log squared n that is to
say the number of items that move around
per insertion deletion in an amortized
sense is log squared n this was then
improved actually to a worst case by
Willard later
from the lower bound side it's known
that you can you can't do better than
log n so there's this gap between login
and log squared n
okay and the question that we're asking
here is you know can we close the gap
between upper and lower bounds
so
before this work the upper bound was
unimproved since like that original work
from the early 80s but there was some
work on the lower bounds but only for
specific cases and specific classes of
algorithms
so to give you some intuition about the
types of lower bounds that were known
let me tell you about kind of just a
natural strategy to get our hands on the
problem of like maybe what's the first
thing you might think of when you're
looking at this problem yes
yes sorry just uh sorry for those of us
who have not seen the problem for let me
ask a very stupid question so
so when I compare it to say a balance
binary surgery the issue is access time
right like your access time is login
necessary when trying to access it but
if you if I if I maintain these elements
if I if I may still maintain the
elements in sorted order
in in an array with gaps I could have
much worse than constant access time I
actually don't know where the element is
so can you so so can you just tell me
what is the advantage of maintaining
this data structure over over a balanced
PST so right so in order to find an
element in the state of structure like
you might have to
do some binary search or something to
actually find elements you don't know
exactly where they're stored um like so
I think you're asking maybe like in
practice what is the benefit of using
like why do people use this and one of
the things that Helen was mentioning she
she'll be the expert on this one of the
things that she was mentioning was like
um it's like contiguous in memory and
you can like just store everything in
one array and scan through it I think is
that okay so she's nodding that but is
there any theoretical difference that
you can point out I
I definitely agree and see the Practical
difference right accessing memories
arrays is way faster but is there any
theoretical question for which bsts are
worse
um okay so the the like there are
theoretical problems that
um
that where the best thing that we do
uses these and this is in like this is a
this is again like in the external
memory model where you care about like
this locality stuff so for example one
of the biggest applications of this
would be um cash oblivious B trees
and those have like are theoretically
defined and you get better bounds based
on this
oh yeah I was going to say
um
basically pretty much exactly what
Nicole said if you're in the external
memory model and you know the cache
parameters then B trees are
asymptotically optimal that we have
lower bounds in that model there are
more modern models like the FI model
that involve parameters for contiguous
access so you can prove that pmas can do
scans asymptotically faster in those
models but yes for the traditional
external memory model if you have the
cache line basically
[Music]
sorry
um you know I I guess one thing I was
confused about are we talking about
upper and lower bounds in terms of
competitive analysis or something
different okay good question so the
upper and lower bounds we're talking
about here are actually just
what is the actual number like how many
elements have to move around each time
you do an insertion deletion you could
think about it in terms of competitive
analysis but it turns out for that for
this problem it's actually the same
thing because if you have an offline
algorithm it can do like constant number
of moves per update like if you have an
algorithm that knows all the insertions
and deletions ahead of time so for this
problem they're actually the same so
we're just counting number of items
well it was just thinking of practical
use the just sometimes
just sometimes I guess you just want to
scan things and sort it all up and the
algorithms would like to do that and
being able to do that just using
consecutive array is much much faster
than trying to use pointers for example
any pointer structure is deadly
so there's another something like that
another answer to sushma's questions
okay uh good so now let me tell you
about
um some lower bounds for this problem
that we're known but only for specific
cases and the specific cases are based
on like
an algorithm that you might consider
like the first time you see this problem
so what a natural strategy for this
problem is like you know you don't want
intervals to become too dense with
elements because then if the adversary
inserts into those intervals you have to
maybe do a lot of work to spread things
out and so a natural strategy is to say
okay when an interval becomes too dense
with elements what we're going to do is
just take a wider interval and spread
out all the elements just completely
evenly
that's what this animation uh is doing
when an interval becomes too dense you
just spread everything out completely
evenly let's wait for one more when
something becomes dense
and we're that became too dense so now
we're spreading everything out in this
wider interval completely evenly okay so
it turns out this strategy is both
you'll notice deterministic as well as
it uses even rebalancing that is to say
whenever you rebalance a region of the
array you're going to do it completely
evenly by spreading the elements out
evenly so those are the strategies that
it's known actually that log squared n
is tight so from the upper bound side
it's known that if you have a
deterministic algorithm or more
generally even if you have an Adaptive
adversary who can see where the elements
are in your array
log squared n is the correct answer
um additionally if you do even
rebalancing
even if you use randomization
again log squared n is the correct
answer and so the question that we're
really asking here when we're saying can
we close this Gap is can we use you know
randomization against an oblivious
adversary
and somehow uneven rebalancing of items
in order to improve over log Square done
and I guess when you first see this or
when I first saw this I thought like
it's it's kind of weird that uneven
rebalancing could maybe help you here
um like if you're doing uneven
rebalancing you're making some areas of
the array dense and some sparse and if
you're making some dents maybe the
adversary could take advantage of that
and just insert into the dense areas and
for most of the time that I spent
thinking about this problem I really
thought that log squared n should be the
correct answer in general but it turns
out that it's not and you can actually
beat log squared n and the main result
that I'll talk about here is that you
can get down to log to the three halves
of n
as an upper Bound for this problem
foreign
again of course this algorithm that
achieves log to the three halves of n it
has to be randomized against an
oblivious adversary and it also has to
use this idea of uneven rebalancing
okay so let me just say two kind of
observations about this result that I
find interesting one of them is that it
turns out that randomization and uneven
rebalancing they actually only help when
your array is of is like
a constant Factor times the number of
items items in the array that's the
version of the problem we're talking
about on the other hand
uh people have also studied the problem
when the array is like a polynomial in
terms of the number of items in the
array and in that case it turns out that
there are upper and lower bounds of log
n that are known and the upper bound is
deterministic and it's tight so somehow
there comes a time when your array gets
denser where suddenly randomization
helps you out
the second observation completely
unrelated is like when you first see
this number into the three half log it
to the three halves then you might think
this seems like kind of an unusual
number and maybe if we can get log to
the three halves then we can get all the
way down to login because that seems
like more of a natural number
um but it turns out that actually log to
the three half cent is tight
for a particular class of algorithms
that I would argue is natural
and that class of algorithms is called
history independent so history
Independence is a concept that in this
talk will be uh of major importance so I
want to make sure I get the definition
of History Independence through to you
here so for history Independence
the idea is that the current state of
the data structure depends only upon
the items that are currently in the data
structure that is to say it does not
depend on any of the history of
insertion solutions that led us up to
this point
okay so you say that you say that an
algorithm is history independent if it
has this property that you that the
state of the data structure only depends
on the elements currently present
this has been a widely studied concept
and usually what people do when they
study this concept is they're saying
okay we have these like data structures
and we also want this additional
property of making them history
independent and just because it's like a
nice property
so let me tell you what history
Independence means for
uh in particular this problem of online
list labeling so you can think of it as
the following so
the probability distribution of occupied
slots in the array depends only on the
number of elements currently present
that is to say if there are 10 elements
in the array we immediately know the
distribution over what slots could be
occupied so here for example you can see
that both of these arrays have you know
nine elements in them and they're
different elements they came from
different histories and but like the
same slots in the array are
occupied and in history Independence
we're not saying that literally the same
slots have to be occupied it's just that
the distribution has to be the same
between these two
okay so yes
so I understand there's probably so
there's a lot of inserts and deletes
that might have gone into resulting in
this yes no matter what they are the
distribution is going to be the same
there's no way I could like insert these
and then delete these Etc that's exactly
right yes
okay so what our result says is that we
have a history independent upper and
lower bounds of log to the three half
sense so if you restrict two algorithms
that only have this that have this
property of History Independence we know
that the correct answer is log to the
three halves of that
that is to say if you want to get
anything below log to the three halves
then you have to give up this property
of History Independence
uh history Independence has been studied
before in the context of this problem
and they got a log squared n solution
that is it matches what was previously
known
so let me say now kind of like the key
point I would say the key conceptual
point of this whole talk
um which is that
okay so previously like I said history
Independence was viewed as kind of a a
property that you would want to kind of
add to an algorithm
and the reason people would want to have
the property of History Independence is
often for kind of security guarantees
like by looking at the data structure I
can't tell what happened in the past
but in contrast what we do in this work
is like we actually use the property of
History Independence in order to achieve
a faster algorithm so it's not an
additional property it's like it turns
out to be kind of useful in the design
of of algorithms and I would say I just
want to draw like kind of a slightly
tenuous connection to thatchupon's talk
earlier this week where he was talking
about differential privacy
because both this and his ideas of
differential privacy follow the general
framework of saying okay let's take some
idea from like security or privacy and
use it in order to fool an adversary
who is doing insertions and deletions
into our data structure so I would say
both of those things are they're very in
different settings but they're kind of
at a high level related
Okay so
um let me say now
kind of why history Independence should
be useful for us
and the reason is the following so in
past work people were saying like for
the sake of security by observing the
state of the data structure I can't tell
any anything about what happened in the
past and what we're doing is kind of
like flipping these two things around
and saying okay by knowing the history
of insertion deletions which the
adversary of course knows because
they're the ones doing the insertion
Solutions if somebody knows the whole
history then they can't tell what is the
state of the current data structure and
because they don't know the state of the
current data structure
they can't like do something clever and
make us have to pay a lot
okay so that's kind of the high level
um thing and now let me get down into
some more kind of details about what's
going on in this algorithm
so I just want to I I didn't follow that
flip of logic there like since they told
all they should know what the data
structure looks like because they
controlled what they did so I don't
understand how they don't know the state
of the data structure good so what so
what I mean by the state of the data
structure here is like in our array what
slots are occupied by elements so what
the adversary is doing is they're just
saying insert H delete a insert J but
they don't know which actual slot in the
data structure is occupied by the
element H for example what information
are they missing it's from the mind
there yeah so they're they're missing
like they they know what elements are in
the data structure they just don't know
where each element is located
that's why you say a distribution is
known as given but not the exact state
they can't figure that out exactly yes
good good
um clarification there so they know the
distribution but they don't know the
exact state
was there another question
foreign
the sort of marginal Distribution on
every entry like the probability that
it's occupied or not or is it like the
joint distribution
over
yeah
you know what I mean I don't think I
understand what you mean so like if I
look at one entry I say the probability
that you know this is occupied
doesn't depend on the history but then I
could also ask for like you know what is
the probability that these three entries
you know are in this particular state
of like occupied unoccupied like
how precise is
uh I think the answer to your question
is that it's the joint one let me
clarify what it is so it's like if I
know that there are 10 elements in the
array I immediately know the
distribution of the occupied slots in
the entire array okay
okay
okay so the first thing that I want to
show you here kind of now to get into
some details getting our hands on the
problem is the classical algorithm so
this is the log squared n algorithm that
was gotten in the first like 1981 paper
this will be kind of the basis for what
I'll be talking about so it will be uh
important so okay what do we do in the
class A Lot classical algorithm so what
they do is they say okay here's your
array now we're going to partition it
into nested intervals so this kind of
forms a tree and then like this
corresponds to this interval here and
Etc
one interval two intervals every time
you are spreading each interval into
dividing it into two more intervals okay
so now what would we like to do here
we're going to do something pretty
intuitive which is to say like I want to
maintain an invariant that says that the
kind of the difference between the
densities of two adjacent intervals with
the same parent are not too different
the reason I would want to do this is
basically I don't want to create inter
sub intervals that are like too dense I
want to make sure that the density of
this interval is about the same as the
density of this interval which is the
same as saying that the density of a
child is about the same as the density
of its parent
we're gonna include this slack factor of
1 over log n for the densities
okay so we want to maintain this
invariant
and first let me tell you that like if
you're able to maintain this invariant
that implies that you kind of have a
valid solution at the bottom that is to
say you're not trying to shove like 10
elements into the same slot so this
invariant implies that actually you only
get like one element per slot at the end
so let's just see that by doing some
densities so the density at the top is
constant just by the definition of the
problem the density on the more dense
side can only increase by like a one
over log n just by the invariant and
then again you can go down and repeat
this and then get at the bottom that the
density is something and if you do the
calculation you get that the density at
the bottom is good it's a constant and
there's enough slots for items
okay so that's just to say that if we
can maintain this invariant then it's
like a valid solution
okay so now I need to tell you what
happens when the invariant is violated
and what happens is maybe the simplest
thing you could think of is which is
that we just totally rebuild that whole
uh interval so if the invariant is
violated here
then we're just gonna say okay this
child is uh much denser let's say than
it's parent we're just going to
completely rebuild the whole entire
parent
so now all of these are going to become
totally evenly spaced
so just to summarize
you
make all of these nested intervals you
maintain this invariant when the variant
is invite is violated you just spread
everything out evenly
uh you can show that there are that this
gives log squared n I'll go through
these calculations kind of quickly you
can do them so log squared n levels and
then for each level we need to do the
cost of the rebuilding on that
particular level
and the idea is that when we rebuild an
interval we're spreading things out
totally evenly
therefore in order to violate the
invariant in the future you need to
make one side much denser than the other
which means you need to do a certain
number of insertions in order to violate
the invariant if you started from it
being spread out evenly and if you do
the calculations then you're saying
every rebuild of an interval of size s
requires s over log n insertion
Solutions in order to be violated
because there's this one as a login
factor and you do the math and it comes
out to log in so those are the two
sources of login
so this announces your
so in this one else is you're assuming
that the cost of rebuilding is basically
the size of the interval is it easy to
force even in the worst case that you
have to I mean like the density is not
that different because it just got
triggered right so you so it's only
slightly higher you still have a lot of
empty locations and hopefully somewhat
evenly spread out what is a what is uh
what is a situation that can arise that
will actually force you to move s
elements in order to actually get a
rebalance between these two children
I see
um
right like the the size difference is is
actually only s over log n
ope the number of excess elements in one
of the child okay so let's say you like
insert a bunch of elements just like at
the very beginning of the interval then
in order to spread everything out evenly
you might have to like take all of those
and like
basically spread everything out in that
whole engine because the thing is you
have to spread everything out in the
whole interval exactly evenly so like
even if things are a little bit off you
have to like maybe move it over by one
to spread everything out exactly evenly
did that answer the
I mean like if you do that you're
actually first going to rebuild already
lower levels right like it will force
you to space them out
already you like you I can't stack at
the beginning just because the moment
I've filled one-fourth of the interval
rebuilding got triggered at one of my
children that already you would have
already paid for that move so it at
least there's some double counting going
on in terms of
so I'm just wondering if I'm lives so
you're basically wondering is there a
better analysis of this particular album
I mean since you said it's tight I
believe you I'm just wondering what is
the example I should think of that here
is a
um here is a bad scenario that can still
arise in this analysis okay I think
maybe it's not easy to explain concisely
maybe we can talk offline about this
point
okay so
um now so that's the classical algorithm
any other questions about how the
classical algorithm works because it'll
be important for what we do in the
future
okay so
um now let me tell you like some of the
ideas behind how you get down to log to
the three half cent over log n log
squared n
and it's going to be kind of an
iterative approach it's going to be okay
let's try this simple idea why does it
not work now let's fix it blah blah so
the first thing that we do is going to
be let's try kind of a simple idea of
lazy rebalancing Okay so
what's the idea here the idea is like if
in the original algorithm the invariant
had been something like 1 over square
root log n instead of one over log n
that is to say we allow things to get we
allow the density differential between
the parent and the child to get much
bigger before we trigger a rebuild then
of course that would be cheaper because
you you're waiting longer until you do
the rebuild
so we can do some wishful thinking and
say okay what if we could just be lazy
here
in that case the cost of maintaining the
invariant would be only log square root
log n at every level if you do those
same calculations as before
and then your final cost would be log to
the three half cent because again you
multiply by log n for the number of
levels so then this is like the answer
that we're going for
okay so if of course this does not work
and the reason it does not work is
because some intervals May overflow
that is to say you'll recall the
calculations from the previous one where
I said if you maintain that invariant
you are not trying to shove like 10
items all into the same array slot that
would happen if you use this
um this different invariant so let's
just kind of redo these calculations if
you replace all the logons with a square
root login then you get at the end that
the density of like one single item is
super constant and that's not a valid
algorithm
so essentially what this means that
there is that if you try to apply this
invariant there's going to be some like
very dense regions that we need to
handle separately so that we prevent the
Overflow from happening
okay so the next thing that we need to
do is to like handle these uh dense
regions of the graph
okay
so
the first thing I want to argue here is
like
uh even though there are some regions
that are going to be of the array that
are going to be experiencing this
overflow there's actually not too many
and that that's the but there's still
hope you know not too many things are
going to be overflowing so maybe there's
hope that you can kind of handle them
and the claim here is that only at most
a one over polylogn fraction of the
array slots are going to be having this
like overflow problem
and you can see this using a relatively
simple proof that I'll go through
quickly
uh which is that okay so our claim is
that only the small fraction of elements
in the array experience overflow and the
proof idea is the following so let's
just pick a random
location of the array
and then let's ask what's the
probability that that one experiences
overflow
so in order to pick a random location in
the array we're going to pick a random
sequence of nested intervals and this
random sequence of nested intervals
you'll notice you can calculate the
density for each one so you know the
density is something here and then here
maybe we went to the denser child or
maybe we went to the sparser child Etc
but in any case it forms a random walk
like we are randomly choosing to go
either to the denser child or the
sparser child
and so by properties of random walks you
can say okay this is a random walk
for login steps each step is of size at
most this one over square root log n
because that's our new invariant on the
difference between the densities and
then you can get at the end that like
with high probability
the density at the bottom is only going
to be a constant which is good
and so the upshot of this thing is that
with high probability over the number of
steps in the walk which is log n
you are not experiencing overflow and on
the other hand at most a one over
polylog n fraction of the intervals do
experience overflow
is the inverse of with high probability
poly login uh good question yes so in
general like we say that with high
probability is like one minus one over
polynomial and n
um but here the like n is log n because
the N is like the number of steps that
we did on this random walk which is log
n and so the if I apply this definition
of with high probability I'm saying it
is uh one over polylogan
Okay so
so now we've shown that we want to do
this new invariant that does lazy
rebalancing
and only a small fraction of uh
intervals in the array experience
overflow but still we need to handle
these places in the array that are very
dense and so what's the solution well
the solution is something quite
intuitive which is like you know if your
interval gets too dense and it looks
like it's about to overflow let's say
it's like nine tenths fraction full or
something then we just revert back to
the log squared on solution for that
particular interval which we already
have
okay so to summarize the situation that
we're in is the following
so for the vast majority of the array
slots they're actually fast to update if
we're lucky and we get an insertion in
one of these sparse areas
then we spend log to the three half cent
on the other hand
there are some dense areas that form one
over polylogon fraction of the array
and those ones are going we're going to
be reverting back to the log squared on
solution so these ones cost log squared
in
and you'll notice here that like
I mean in some sense it seems as if
we've made no progress whatsoever
because like the adversary
we're still vulnerable to the adversary
I'm claiming because what's the
adversary going to do like in this
situation
like let's just insert always into the
dense spots and make you pay log squared
and every single time and then we
haven't made any progress whatsoever
over the classical solution
Okay so
now what we would like to do is kind of
hide yes
you said it's oblivious
exactly so that's what we need to take
advantage of right now so right now all
we have is like a deterministic
algorithm and the adversary could know
where these dense regions are but what
we need to do now is to hide the dense
regions from the adversary so that
there's a low chance that they'll
actually hit one of these expensive
places
okay so how are we going to hide the
dense regions from the adversary and
that's where this concept of History
independence from before comes into play
Okay so
let me be a little bit more specific
about what the problems are that we have
here so
one problem is that the adversary can
create dense regions that is to say the
adversary could do insertions and
deletions in a very clever manner in
order to make a particular area of the
array dense
one way a dense region could be created
a second way that a dense region could
be created is that actually the
specification of the algorithm creates
dense regions like the way that the
algorithm moves around items creates
dense regions
so these are kind of two distinct
problems and let's focus on the first
one first so the the solution to the
first one is this idea of History
Independence so now I'm going to argue
to you like if you had an algorithm that
was history independent then the
adversary cannot create dense regions
okay so the question here is like
why does history Independence prevent
the adversary from creating dense
regions
and the answer is essentially like by
definition that is
by the definite definition of History
Independence we know that the
probability distribution of occupied
slots depends only on the number of
elements currently present so whatever
the adversary did in the past they did
some clever sequence of insertions
deletions to try to thwart you like who
cares they didn't do anything though
because the distribution of occupied
slots it only depends on the fact that
there's like 10 elements in the array so
it doesn't matter what the adversary did
in the past
that is to say if we had an algorithm
that had this property of History
Independence then we could say okay the
adversary cannot like create it has no
control over where the debts regions in
the array are
just a quick question about like the
algorithm itself
um
like do you switch back and forth on
regions between like if so you said if a
region gets too dense you switch to the
the log square and regime but you also
have to switch back yes good question
yes you switch back as well
so just just follow her there this
wouldn't get history into Pence but is
it clear you couldn't like randomize
where the regions are just not a big the
tree so balanced and
and therefore like the dense regions
don't align and the adversary doesn't
know where they are fine right so like
using basically that type of brand like
we use basically that type of
randomization in order to achieve
history Independence in order to argue
this thing it's possible that you could
use that type of randomization and not
achieve history Independence but then
maybe the argument would become like
more complicated to argue that the
adversary actually doesn't have any
information or has only limited
information about where the dense
regions are
okay
okay so then for the second issue
basically it's also solved by history
Independence
um this is a detail in the algorithm
that is
maybe not even necessary it just makes
things easier and I don't think it's
very important conceptually basically we
do like a random shift to a history
independent algorithm which consists of
inserting random a random number of like
dummy elements at the beginning of the
end so that the like active region of
the array is not clear to the adversary
I don't want us to dwell on that one too
much basically history Independence is
the important uh concept here for hiding
the dense regions
okay so
um
so far we've said if we had a history
independent algorithm that would be
great we could hide these dense regions
but the problem is okay now we have to
find a history independent algorithm but
some of our work was done for us by this
prior work so they got a log squared n
cost history independent algorithm
and it turns out that the structure of
their algorithm is similar to the
classical algorithm
uh in the sense that it uses the same
like nested intervals and you are
rebalancing at certain times and the
main difference between this algorithm
and the other one is that the rebalances
are have some Randomness involved in
them
you're not just deterministically doing
it smoothly
so what that means is that you can like
take their algorithm as a starting point
and basically apply the whole entire
previous talk with lazy rebalancing and
dense regions and fixing things and then
that's how you get our algorithms so let
me summarize what actually our algorithm
is so like you start off with their
previous history independent algorithm
similar to the classical algorithm but
it has some Randomness in the
rebalancing
then what you do is this like random
shift thing which I wanted to not dwell
on
then you do this lazy rebalancing thing
which is you're saying again the
invariant of the density between the
child and the parent is going to be
relaxed to this like 1 over square root
log n factor and what this does is it
speeds up the algorithm to log to the
three half Zen cost for most of the
array but then of course we still have
these dense regions and we have to
revert back to the log squared n
algorithm for these dense regions
the purpose of that is to prevent
overflow and again you'll recall that
the invariant for this part is this like
one over log n density differential
and these are actually the only
ingredients in the algorithm if you're
allowed to allow yourself to have extra
log log factors if you want to get rid
of the log log factors then actually
what you want to do is like smoothly
vary the density threshold that is here
we just have two cases basically dents
and sparse where we do to do two
different things if you want to get rid
of log log factors you can kind of
smoothly vary the density threshold and
have a hierarchy of different uh like
densities
okay so that's essentially what I wanted
to tell you about how the algorithm
Works any questions here
you say just something about what
uh about what the randomization is
inside the rebalancing yes so it's
actually not too difficult to describe
so the randomization and the rebalancing
is like okay here's an interval
and you'll notice that in order to
maintain the invariant there's a
particular set of vertices
that could uh go in the middle of this
interval so like for example
uh let's say like here are all my
elements that are in this interval
uh if I if I decided to place I in the
middle
that would be bad that would that would
mean that everything else was on this
side and and zero things were on this
side we would violate the invariant that
is to say there's a certain group of
elements in the Middle where we're
allowed to put them as the actual middle
element here
and the invariant is not violated
and you choose uniformly at random from
this middle
could you comment on where this root log
is coming from like why not choose a
different parameter I'm sure it's coming
from some yes balancing yes it does come
from somewhere and the place that it
comes from is like this random walk
thing
so this is where it comes from
essentially
um it turns out that if you if your step
size
um
so so okay so what what is it it uses
like the fact of random walks that if I
take a random walk for end steps with
high probability I I'm within square
root n from the origin that's
essentially where the square root log n
comes from
and that is to say that here when I'm
doing a random walk on the densities of
the intervals if I were to have chosen a
different number than square root log n
at the end I wouldn't have gotten that
with high probability
uh you don't experience overflow that is
if I chose something different I would
actually have like many many suddenly
places in the array that do experience
overflow and therefore many many dense
regions in the array and this allows us
to only have a couple of dense regions
in the array
that makes sense
so I guess we're in the middle of the
questions session do we have any final
slides you'd like to show oh thank you I
totally forgot about it okay I'll just
finish with some like summary of open
questions so okay one last thing to
recall is that like we show a matching
lower Bound for history independent
algorithms so if you want to be log to
the three halves then it has to be
history dependent
and so just to summarize what is the
main open question here now it's like
can we now close the gap between login
and log to the three halves then and you
know you can kind of come up with
different reasons of like
maybe log to the three half cent is
correct because history Independence is
you know hides information from the
adversary and you need that or maybe you
can actually get lower than log to the
three half cent because history
Independence is like too strong of a
property to be able to maintain whatever
so uh the the the the the main question
is between those two can we close it and
if there's an algorithm that actually
gets better than log of the three half
Senate has to have several properties it
has to be randomized against some of
these adversary it has to use uneven
rebalancing and it also has to be
history dependent
um and then just to say something more
broadly
uh in this work we used the idea of
History Independence to kind of hide
information from an adversary and
there's now the question of like could
you maybe use a similar type of idea to
do this for some other problems
[Applause]
he said it
if you don't want to maintain this fully
sorted but just want to scan property
have people explored data structures
which maybe have two sorted list or
small unsorted and small one and like a
big one and they kind of keep extra
information and get better performance
so
are when you say a small one and a big
one so I'm just thinking like in your
algorithm you have this overflow and
when you overflow you kind of like shove
them into a second small list right and
I'm just wondering in the space of this
you want to maintain pointless data
structure for efficiency in various scan
operations right
but then if you're not sorted then
you'll incur search cost
but you know is there some in between
where you take advantage of like maybe
you only want like a certain number of
layers of of uh or else two or three and
and then I'm just asking about internal
space because I don't know much yeah I
not sure if this has been formally site
do you happen to know if this is
the
yeah I
yeah I'm not sure if it has been studied
I mean you're right that like
we do a lot of work to try to make it
one and if you could just allow one more
layer it seems like it would make things
a lot easier
um what about worst case at the time
yeah good question so that's a open
question so our algorithm is uh the
probability is in expectation so that
translates to amortized so getting worst
case uh for logs of the three half cent
is a good open question
I don't know if you can say anything
about it quickly but uh can we say
something about how you use history
Independence for the logon history
Independence for the lower bound oh for
the lower bound yeah I can say maybe
like one kind of nugget from the lower
bound so the way that it essentially
works is like you can imagine like if
you insert a you have like some interval
of the array and you like insert a bunch
of elements at the beginning of that
interval and then you delete a bunch of
elements at the end of that interval
then if you had 10 elements to begin
with you have 10 elements at the end
because I inserted a bunch and I deleted
a bunch and what history independent
says is that you have to have the same
distribution at the beginning and at the
end but because I inserted a bunch of
stuff at the beginning and deleted from
the end like now there's a lot more
stuff at the beginning and I need to
like spread that stuff out in order to
get the same distribution at the
beginning and then
are there any kind of customers
so are you curious um
what is the actual distribution of
elements in the array like is there an
easy way to describe like the I'm
viewing the Superman as like uh maybe
like a distribution of binary strings
zero than one or one is like different
elements in the array of that position
is there an easy way to describe this
distribution of let's say binary streams
um
I would say not really like the easiest
way to describe it would be to say what
is the algorithm used to create it which
is basically to like pick a uniform
random element in the middle section of
the things put that in the middle do
that recursively but then there's the
extra caveat that if something becomes
too dense you do something different so
I I don't think there's really such an
easy way to just describe what the
distribution is thanks
all right uh then let's close this
session
um we'll be here for another talk at 2
pm and let's thank Nicole again for this
very nice interactive talk
[Applause]